You know,
lots of times soldiers develop post
traumatic stress disorder because they
go out in the battlefield,
they're kind of naive.
They're young guys,
you know,
and,
uh,
it actually is worse if they're not that
bright.
It turns out because having a lower Iq
is one of the things that predisposes
you to post traumatic stress disorder.
But anyways,
they go out in the battlefield and they
see what they're capable of under
battlefield conditions.
And like,
you know,
we,
we've been fighting wars for a very long
time,
millions of years.
You know,
chimps basically have wars with other
chimps,
the troops,
right?
Cause the juveniles will patrol the
perimeter perimeter of their territory.
And if they find other chimps from other
troops that they outnumber,
they will tear them to pieces like in
chimps are really,
really strong.
And so when I say they'll tear them to
pieces,
I mean that literally,
you know,
they,
they tear them to pieces.
And Jane Goodall discovered that
originally in 1970s she didn't even
report it for a while because she was so
shocked.
You know,
she kind of assumed like most followers
of roots so that the human proclivity
for warfare was part,
that part that was something that was a
uniquely human.
You know,
it had something to do with our,
our unique self consciousness or our
intelligence or something like that.
She had no idea that it was rooted that
deeply.
You know,
we split from chimps about six,
7 million years ago,
something like that.
And so we were patrolling territory.
We were gang members 7 million years
ago.
And you know,
it that that's,
that's minimum estimation because of
course that ancestor shaded back maybe
20 million years into entities that were
roughly primate like,
and so territoriality and a,
and a proclivity to defend territory is
so deeply embedded in us.
It's,
it's,
it's like,
it's like it's the control center for
our whole brain.
And so there isn't anything more
important to us,
I would say.
Then maintaining the match between what
we want to have happen and what other
people are doing in response to our
actions.
Like that's that that's what we want.
And as long as that match is maintained,
then our emotional systems,
and I would say anxiety's probably
primary in that regard.
Our emotional systems remain inhibited.
They're on,
they're ready,
like,
like a nuclear reactor.
Rods are on and the rest of the brain
dampens them down.
But it's like it,
you don't want them to take time to
start it up,
man.
You want them to be on at a,
at a 10th of a second's notice when it's
necessary.
And so,
you know,
that's kind of why,
well if you look like look at a wild
animal,
it's like it's alert,
it's ready to dark this way or that way,
especially a prey animal
instantaneously.
And it has reflexes built into it.
As you do that,
we'll respond way before your conscious.
So for example,
if you happen to be walking down a trail
and you detect something snake,
like in the periphery,
you'll leap away before you even know
that you lapped.
And,
but that's because it takes a fair bit
of time to actually see a snake.
By which I mean form a conscious
representation of the snake,
you know?
And maybe it takes a quarter of a second
or something like that,
or even longer,
but it doesn't matter.
Maybe it takes,
you know,
20th of a second,
a 10th of a second.
But the thing about the damn snake is
it's way faster than that.
It's really fast.
That thing and it coevolved with
primates by the way.
And so it can nail you like way faster
than you can look at it.
So you have your eyes map snake like
objects right onto your reflexes so that
the eyes go,
the eyes make you jump,
and then they see after that it's like,
yeah,
well now you can see that's no problem.
You know,
so all right.
All right.
Now what I would say that what we do is
we live in a shared story and the story
is a way of looking at the world and its
way of acting in the world at the same
time.
And that story has to operate within
narrow parameters.
And this is something that's
extraordinarily important to understand
because,
and this is something I think that
Piaget figured out,
John Piaget figured out better than
anyone else.
I think he really got this right.
And by the way,
one of the things that Piaget was trying
to do,
you never hear about how strange these
great thinkers are.
But Piaget was a very strange guy and he
was a,
he was a hyper genius and he was offered
the curatorship of a bloody museum when
he was 10 years old.
You know,
cause he wrote this little paper on
molluscs which parent?
It was a very good,
so they offered him the curatorship of a
museum and his parents wrote back and
said,
well you know,
no,
probably not because he's,
he's actually 10 and so that was Piaget
man.
The guy was a genius.
And you know,
he,
he was actually motivated by the desire
to reconcile science and religion.
That was,
that was actually his entire motivation
for what he did.
You never hear that.
But that's,
that's the case.
And so Piaget was very interested in how
you produce structures that enable you
to regulate yourself.
Cause you're like a kind of a,
a colony of strange sub animals that
have to figure out how to get along so
that you can sort of be one thing.
You kind of learn that,
I would say between the ages of two and
four as you're being socialized,
you know how erratic two year olds are.
I mean,
they're a blast.
And it's partly because they were
erratic.
It's like they're unbelievably happy and
then they're unbelievably hungry and
then they're really hot.
And then they're really upset and
crying,
you know?
And then they're really scared.
It's like,
and all of that's just untrammeled.
And so it's really fun to be around
them,
especially when they're happy because
they're so happy that it's just,
you know,
you don't ever get to be that happy.
And so it's nice to be around a two year
old because you can kinda feel that
again,
you know?
And a lot of what the,
one of the horrible things about being a
parent is that you spend a tremendous
amount of your time making your child
less happy.
And the reason for that is that positive
emotion is a very impulsive,
you know,
and you know,
cause everybody says,
well you should be happy.
It's like,
well no,
when you're happy you're actually quite
stupid.
And so because happiness makes you
impulsive,
happiness makes happiness,
says,
hey,
things are really good right now.
Get Wet.
You can while the getting's good.
And so as a like if you're a hyper
optimistic manic,
we'll say it's like every stock
investment looks like a really good
stock investment.
It's like you won't spend all your money
because look at,
there's those wonderful things
everywhere and you could do such great
things with them.
And then,
you know,
you spend all your money and then you
crash and you think,
Oh God,
my life's over.
You know,
cause I just,
I just spent all my money on all this
useless stuff.
And it's all under the grip of
impulsive,
positive emotion,
you know?
And so when,
when you're telling your kids to be
quiet and settled down,
it isn't because they're making a lot of
noise.
Being in pain is because they're running
around like wild baboons having a blast.
And disrupting things like mad,
you know,
and say,
wow,
you got kids,
you got to settle down,
you know,
like quit having so much fun.
And it's,
it's kind of awful that you do that,
but,
but you do.
And that's because the emotions and the
motivations have to be brought into like
a relationship with one another within
the person.
So that,
you know,
one thing I remember with my son who is
quite,
he's quite disagreeable by temperament,
which is actually a good thing as far as
I'm concerned,
although it brings its own challenges.
And so with my daughter,
when she was misbehaving,
she was pretty agreeable and uh,
you know,
if she was misbehaving,
I can basically just look at her and
then she'd quit,
you know,
but my son,
it was like,
that was just nothing.
You're looking at me.
It's like,
no,
that's just not going to go anywhere,
man.
And so then I'd like tell him to stop.
And that really wasn't having much of an
effect either.
He just sort of maybe laugh or run away
or whatever.
I mean,
he was a tough little rat.
And you know what?
I would do with him is he would be doing
something and identity or,
and he'd get upset and you know,
angry.
And so then I get them to sit on the
steps and I had told him,
this is when he was about to,
I said,
look,
you're going to sit on the steps.
That's time out.
You're going to sit on the steps until
you've got control of yourself and you
can come back and be and play the family
game again.
I basically said,
be a civilized human being and then
you're welcome again.
And so he'd sit on the steps.
It was so interesting to watch because
he was just enraged.
He'd sit there like if you ever seen a
two year old have a temper Tantrum,
it's really quite the bloody phenomena.
If you ever saw an adult do that,
you'd like,
you'd call nine one one right away.
It's like,
oh my God.
And I've seen adults do that.
You know,
because people say with borderline
personality disorder will have temper
tantrums and it's like,
man,
you want to be about 30 feet away from
that person.
That's for sure.
It's really,
but in kids it's like,
well first of all,
they're only this long,
so how much trouble can they really
cause?
But it's like,
you know,
they're just completely gone there.
Like on the floor or their face is red.
They're just furious.
Like way more furious than you ever get
if you're even vaguely socialized there.
Just outraged and they're kicking and
hitting the ground and like,
it's like a little epileptic fit of
anger.
You know,
they're completely controlled by their
rage.
And we took care of one kid for a while
who he was actually a pushover,
that kid,
you could get them to behave by,
you know,
kind of shaking your finger at him.
But his mother thought he was really
tough because he had her,
he had her figured out and one of the
things he would do is have a territory
temper tantrum.
And during the temper tantrum he would
hold his bloody breath until he turned
blue.
It's like,
try that.
Like,
you know,
as that's your homework,
go home and go home and have a temper
tantrum and while you're doing it,
hold your breath until you actually turn
blue.
It's like you won't be able to do it.
You don't have the willpower of a two
year old now.
That's for sure.
That little varmint man,
he just have a fit.
Then he'd hold his breath and then he'd
turn blue.
It was like,
wow,
that's,
that's amazing.
And we would just like,
let him do it.
You know,
he turned blue and everybody would be
gone and he'd come out of it,
you know,
and it didn't work.
So he just quit doing it.
I think he did it like twice and he
figured out,
oh well that's a lot of work for very
little outcome.
And you know,
it's not like two year olds are stupid.
They're,
they're not stupid.
They're probably smarter than you,
but they're not civilized by any stretch
of the imagination.
And so anyways,
back to my son,
I'd put him on the steps and he'd be
like,
[inaudible] just like aged and,
and trying to get himself together,
you know?
And I wait a few few,
I kind of strict rule,
which was as soon as you're done,
you're welcome again.
So it's completely under your control.
You,
you get yourself calmed down,
you come and talk to me again.
If you're calm enough,
so I like you,
then you're welcome back in the family.
No grudge or nothing.